Um, but one, I have six minutes, 55 seconds to get through a whole lot of slides.
And I get the pleasure of talking about where we are today with the addition of monoclonal
antibodies, CD38, specifically daratumumab, um, in our quadruple therapy for both newly
diagnosed ineligible, whatever that word means anymore, ineligible slash deferred folks.
Okay.
At this point in time, and again, not to pick sides, but yeah, transplant is a wonderful
thing, but maybe we can do something without it.
Long story short is I think our goal should be, and you'll see in the next slide, our
goal has to be MRD negativity, which to me means we're all looking to try to cure these
folks as best we can.
We know when everybody gets there, we know it's not all long lived for everybody.
But again, as you'll see, as we go through today's, what we do today, therapy session
versus later on, we're doing tomorrow in the context of curing patients.
And again, we use that word now.
I don't think we've done a great job of it, but I think we're getting closer and closer
and closer.
So to me, deep, durable responses, meaning MRD negative, meaning curing.
We can't measure 10 to the minus six, which is what we have today.
We know it still doesn't mean everybody's gone, but we, no matter what, if you achieve
that goal, you can do better at any time of disease.
But what's changed over the last several years is really the addition of monoclonal
antibodies to CD38 to our induction therapies.
Okay.
For both, again, ineligible slash deferred.
Ineligible patients, there are two members that when I get the opportunity to talk about
this morning and the studies that go along with it, but again, it's critically in its
addition to our therapy and the way it works in terms of adding to our IMID, PI, and dexamethasone
backbone have really made remarkable additions.
To our therapy and how well we do today.
There's been a whole lot of studies on here leading to the approval of quads and newly
diagnosed transplant eligible patients.
You don't read them all.
We're going to focus a little bit on Perseus today, but again, Griffin, we participated
kind of led to this great changes, maintenance therapy, advanced master.
We're going to talk a little bit about just because of how they're changing, how we should
think about taking care of our patients against stopping therapy, things like that, using
risk and response adaptive ways of addressing our therapeutic needs.
But again, we've heard a lot about this.
So I don't want to talk a lot about the details these days, but essentially what happens if
we add daratumab to a VRD backbone, both with induction, with transplant and a maintenance
therapy.
And I think we all kind of understand the results of this, which is, Hey, you get a
lot better MRD results.
You get a lot better responses at MRD to the minus five to the minus six.
These are things that are again, remarkably better when you add one drug daratumab to
these therapies.
And again, you'll hear from Tom in a little bit that it's not unique to daratumab, it's
unique to the fact that these are fantastic therapeutics.
We know that getting to MRD is good, right?
Whether you're VRD or DRVD in this setting, getting MRD negativity and sustained is a
really good thing.
But the deal is with adding daratumab, you're getting a whole lot more patients to that
end point.
So again, our goal is to be making these patients have no disease that we can find, whether
it be risk-responsive or et cetera.
Again, PFS, we know this, again, all subtypes, we know that it's going to be better.
And these are all fantastic results with p-values.
You know, PES ratios that are fantastic.
What about transplant ineligible, deferred patients, right?
Is this for everybody?
We all had this concept where less people, really less therapy.
It's true within smaller and smaller groups of patients because these therapies are so
well tolerated.
The patients can tolerate this, especially when you use the right doses.
Not all patients need high full doses of everything.
But again, these are patients looking at quad therapy versus triplet therapy and transplant
ineligible and deferred patients.
Again, Maya was fantastic.
You know, we know the other studies have shown that there are a lot more patients that are
looking at quad therapy versus triplet therapy.
They're looking at quad therapy versus triplet therapy.
I don't know.